[Music]
this is star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and
sports enthusiast that's why we do
sports edition and i got with me gary
o'reilly of course gary hi neil all
right former soccer pro over in the uk
and current soccer announcer uh it's
great thanks for sharing some of your
announcing time with us over here in
sports edition like gary you were
cooking up something for this
installment uh yes you got some recipe
that you didn't share with me in advance
so let me let me hear what you got going
now all right so we've gone back to an
old recipe uh from our playing with
science days and brought forward
a show about the sky hook the sky hook
isn't like a missile from the original
star wars movie or anything spectacular
like that it is the signature shot from
kareem abdul-jabbar nba legend and
martial arts expert now
this shot
just to be clear he's not just any old
martial arts person he was trained by
one of the best
that being bruce lee bruce lee of course
in one of his movies now there's 38 387
points which is the record all-time
points tally in nba history kareem owns
that he hasn't played for 30 odd years
yet he still owns it that's how lethal a
shot this skyhook is and with you
talking to him you break down the
mechanics the geometry and the physics
and he understood all of that that was
quite the conversation that i had i
distinctly remember that i mean he was
sitting in my office and his legs i
don't know if i should interview his
legs or him you know what's the
difference
he's seven foot two the boots tall
and the thing is the story behind the
story is very star talk for us so we
found two of his teammates from the la
lakers during that eighties decade the
most successful decade in lakers history
the dynasty yeah yes the dynasty
showtime and we spoke to jamal wilkes
and michael cooper and we unlocked
stories of what it was like to be part
and parcel of that whole sporting
franchise now there's a lovely little
human interest story one of the players
jamal and michael
their grandmother has glycoma and she
can't see the tv as well so
the player decides that he will do
something
on court that will enable his
grandmother to see that it's him playing
on court so i'd like those people to
listen and then they'll understand what
that is and if it doesn't touch you then
go and get yourself checked out because
you might just have a heart of stone
okay or no hard at all
well as i say gary let's roll tape
i'm gary o'reilly and i'm chuck nice and
this is playing with science yes indeed
today's show is a bit different because
we're featuring the first of our game
changer series a series where we take a
single athlete and examine how they
straight up broke the game and rebuilt
it to suit their own style yeah so to
tip us off we have chosen a man who
nearly 30 years after he retired is
still the nba's leading all-time point
scorer a man who owns six count em six
nba titles and uh acting career that
boasts a bruce lee movie as well as the
airplane movie what hasn't this man done
we're gonna find out but there's not
much he hasn't done a player who
invented his own shot the skyhook have
we worked it out yet um for such an
offensive weapon it might surprise you
to know he ranks still ranks third in
the mba's all-time records for not just
rebounds bud blocks yeah ladies and
gentlemen the man who changed the game
of basketball we're talking none other
than kareem abdul-jabbar and to help us
take a trip down memory lane we asked
neil degrasse tyson to hook up with the
man himself while we wrap with former
lakers superstars and teammates michael
cooper
and jamal wilkes yeah we'll talk let's
do it do this we need to do this and
first to kick things off joining us by
video call we are super excited to have
jamal wilkes better known as silk what's
up jamal
hey chuck how you doing hey gary it's a
pleasure to be with you guys
the pleasure is us
just to talk to any of the guys who were
around that organization at that time is
such a thrill for us because
you just reinvented the game and let
alone what kareem did on his own yeah i
mean by i mean when you look at the
dynasty that you guys had
and
the type of talent that was brought on
to this nba team you look at just look
at you i mean come on uh rookie of the
year right if if i remember uh three
times three three time nba all-star if
if i remember uh nicknamed silk because
we know you had the stroke uh i mean
this
this team was always
just chock full of superstars all of you
i mean no matter where you look so you
know before we uh before we get into how
it is to play as a superstar on a team
of superstars you know we're talking
about jamal so let's take um we're
talking about i'm sorry jamal we're
talking about kareem you're all talking
about japan but we're also talking about
jamal and a little bit a little bit
later we're gonna talk to uh michael
cooper who i'm sure you were familiar
with uh but let's take a look at a
quintessential kareem clip so that we
can see exactly what we're talking about
when we say how he changed the game of
basketball with the skyhook let's do it
magic the distance gives the kareem slam
save still saved it throws it to kareem
48 out play what an athlete
is this dribble i'll say nobody else
could have kept their balance nobody
could have caught up with it inside it
goes to kareem against perry back to
cooper back to kareem swing left shoot
right through 12. that's good kareem has
got
[Music]
tickle the twine 48-48 clark's got the
ball 50 to 48 the lakers trailer michael
cooper with the ball uber dribbling at
the top of the key magic getting a long
rest ball into kareem gonna swing left
again and shoot right from 13. and there
it is again perry says come on he's up
big fella
and there he says
so you know the thing about the skyhook
and you could hear it from the
announcers uh pov
it's the same move but it just seems to
be indefensible swing left move right
up boom uh can you can you talk about
what it what it was like to
witness somebody who's
has an indefensible shot absolutely well
first of all when you talk about kareem
uh
he was a perfectionist and i tell people
had he been six feet tall
he'd have been a great basketball player
he was just so fundamentally sound at
everything he did and he could bring a
level of concentration that was just
otherworldly but the sky hook in
particular it's the most
devastating offensive weapon
in any sport that i've ever seen okay
and and
it was a very simple shot
but he he mastered it it was just
just an amazing experience to see that
shot day in and day out not just the
games but practices too i mean he he
practiced
with all of us he didn't take off
practice he was just a
a leader by example he wasn't the most
talkative individual then back then but
you know he always led with his example
it was just a a sheer
delight to play with him so uh neil
degrasse tyson actually caught up with
kareem recently to chat about the
legendary sky hook and uh we have a clip
of their conversation so let's take a
take a listen what percent of your 38
000 points were sky hook points would
you guess
i'd say three quarters three quarters
yeah
but you know i learned
everything i learned you know had to do
with learning the mechanics of the shot
and
shooting a bow and arrow
because she
figure out
what the drop is all about you know what
the arc is all about and once you get
got that figured out you can
you become
accurate you're a marksman at that point
so you're a basketball marksman
you have to be
well if you're going to be successful
you know
and i led the league in um field goal
percentage a number of years i think
that was really my success too you know
i had a successful shot that they
couldn't block that's what
enabled me to endure what's intriguing
about this hook shot
i think uh bill bradley famously was
quoted saying
that in the hookshot because he also did
the hook shot the hook shot
your eyes are not on the ball or on your
hand
or anywhere near your arm
so that there's a sense
of where the basket is relative to the
ball
if you have enough experience on the
court so you don't actually need to look
at where the basket is and you must
agree with that because you were
successful in the cook shot you don't
have to know where the ball is
you got to keep your eye on the basket
but you don't have to have your eye on
the ball
okay but that requires some
musculoskeletal
connectivity yes
that's why you practice
that's the quote of the interview
practice that's why you practice so
jamal would you pass out what your mom
was saying i know you said that so is is
was everybody aware of you know kareem's
work ethic because i have to tell you i
remember watching
um you guys play
and because it was showtime everybody
had such uh an emphasis on the fact that
there were all these big personalities
these big superstars on the court nobody
you didn't hear anybody talking about
the practice you didn't hear anybody
talking about the work ethic you didn't
hear anybody like when you talk when
they talk about lebron james today they
always talk about how hard he practices
and how much he's trying to drive the
team uh you heard that a lot about
michael jordan oh this guy he practices
his work ethic his work ethic when and
you guys were a dynasty and all they
talked about was like oh the show is in
town it almost made it seem like you
guys just walked out on the court and it
just happened like that
talk to me about like your routine as a
team to get to that place because i'm
sure there's a lot of hard work involved
oh you're you're absolutely right chuck
and and i couldn't agree with you more
they all talk about the work lebron and
michael jordan but no one talks about
that with kareem and
you know
i'm
it may have to do with the fact that
he's seven feet tall it seems like
people just assume you're automatically
good
in basketball because you're tall and
that's why i say that even if he was six
feet he's been he'd have been a top top
basketball player i mean this guy was
just
really really uh good at everything and
and uh and and i agree i couldn't agree
with you more chuck no one ever said
that about showtime never no one ever
talked about how how hard we work i mean
i remember when we played the celtics
yeah they were blue collar guys they
were
and we were hollywood right yeah
uh but we worked hard uh
and we our practices were as competitive
as our games and i mean kareem did not
take practices off he he he worked just
as hard as all of us did and
um uh and it's it's it's unfortunate
that
that gets overlooked and and it's all
about the glitz and the glamour but not
about
uh the preparation the planning and the
effort the hard work that that we all
put into it including kareem all right
let's play a little bit of fantasy
basketball
how would the 80s lakers fare in the nba
today with that pound for pound talent
come on you must have been asked this
question before look at that smiling
face look at that face
okay gary i'm going to ask you a soccer
question
all right by all means
because i
there isn't a day goes by when i don't
get better
uh
you know uh it's hard to compare
different errors um right
and and and and and and we all do it in
the fans
and the media loves it and it drives
interest in the game i get that but i
just have to say it's very difficult but
we would have fared very well i mean
today number we had everything we had
yes complete the ultimate inside game
and with the outside game now we weren't
shooting three pointers
back then like they do today only
because it wasn't in vogue had it been
in vogue
we'd have been doing it too so i you
know i don't want to make predictions i
think we have some great teams today
some great players today but we would
have held our own we'd have done very
well it's funny to hear you say it
wasn't in vogue to shoot three-pointers
back then because uh during the time
that you guys were playing and magic was
running the point and i remember
all the kids who played basketball
wanted to be like magic and so it was
all about ball handling it was all about
no look passing it was all about how
fancy and how good i could look uh
getting the ball on a feed or faking a
feed and going to the hole like so it's
funny yeah
they replicated that that the game
changes based on
who the stars of the game are at that
time and then the next generation
emulating those stars they actually
change the game based on what they have
seen
yeah no you're absolutely correct uh it
is interesting yeah magic was a game
changer too and and you know magic was
just an incredible freak of nature you
know being six foot nine point guard
hailing the ball the way he did seeing
the floor the way he did and those
no-look passes
before he came you frown down upon him
but he delivered him consistently that
they became
part of the game i think we're seeing
that today with
the warriors and steph curry and the
step back and going left and right but
uh
uh
getting back to
kareem uh
and and your point chuck about how hard
lebron and michael were it really is
unfortunate that the hard work he put in
gets overlooked with the skyhook which
is a just a thing of beauty to watch uh
whether you whether you like basketball
or not it's a beautiful thing to watch
and speaking of the skyhook being a
thing of beauty we have another clip
where neil degrasse tyson is talking to
kareem abdul-jabbar and they kind of
break down the physics of the sky hook
and so it's a thing of beauty not only
to look at but it's a thing of beauty in
the world of physics too let's check it
out when i look at a basketball game
part of me sees it as a physicist does
so there's a ball it's round there's a
hoop which is bigger than the ball
and they're all manners of shots that
come at it from different angles
different
trajectories
and
your sky hook
your hand at fully extended
has got to be like eight or nine feet in
the air i mean did they measure this
when i shot this guy hooked my hand was
about
between
10 feet and 10 and 11 feet in the air
because you're also jumping yeah i'm
also jumping okay so now the rim is 10
feet up exactly temperature so the ball
is basically going down
so the the physics of this of course is
the more the ball can just go down
right the greater
chance it is chance it has for going in
right so you want to you want to shoot a
high arcing shot
that drops the drops you don't want to
just get it to crawl over if it just
crawls over then there's the cross
section
changes much smaller right i don't
people know that so so i could take this
circle and angle it the cross section t
was smaller now right so you want to get
your shot should have a high arc
and come straight down
are you thinking about that physics when
you were taking that shot because you
had your physics class i
understood what i wanted to do so
i had all the ballistics and everything
worked out
you see jamal did he did you ever get
the feeling that kareem just had
everything under control when i saw the
sky hook i mean i i
just marveled i would think of picasso i
would think of wow all right i would
think of john coltrane i would think of
the hendrix i would think of
that's the only way i could think of it
because it was you know it was so
uh separate and apart from what anyone
else was doing at that time especially
the centers and no one's done it since
and i i can't believe that you know all
these seven footers now want to shoot
three pointers no one wants to shoot a
sky hook anymore so
uh
uh it was just
then even then watching it i knew and i
think most of us have an idea that you
know
this just wasn't a shot this was you
know art
music on the highest level
uh and it was just just uh you know i
mean i already said it a thing of beauty
i can't express it any other way i'm
happy with that
absolutely i can't i i can't think of a
better compliment than to call somebody
what somebody does uh coltrane
it doesn't get any better than that yeah
that's right that's right
it does not get any better than that so
what we're going to do right now is take
a quick break and jamal you can stand by
with us right
yeah uh fantastic so look guys we got
more jamal wilkes coming your way more
kareem abdul-jabbar more sky hook more
everything stay tuned
welcome back i'm gary o'reilly
and we are playing with science let's
get straight to our next clip the hook
shot yes the famous hook shot made
famous by kareem abdul-jabbar but what
about the hook shot today let's find out
what the big man has to say
for me the hook shot is
unjustifiably accurate
i took hook shocks my whole life
and i was pretty good at it
metal lock lemon
in the globetrotters harlem
globetrotters that was he go the other
end of the court and just throw the
thing up
swish so
why doesn't anyone shoot it anymore
i think
the hook shot has fallen out of
favor because
all the kids that are learning how to
play the game want to shoot
three-pointers they don't want that
ugly
two-point shot down there in the paint
uh getting bumped they want to look real
pretty
out at 35 feet
with something dropping in
everybody's saying ooh
it looks pretty good in the hand doesn't
it
it's three points you know
so it's uh
the three-point shot has changed the
game
that that's uh
basically what it is we've got former
teammate jamal wilkes with us and want
to explore that jamal thank you for
staying with us
why why why why why why did the sky hook
disappear off the map what happened
yeah it's unbelievable
to me i uh i think much of it has to do
with
uh the hype of the game now they on the
news world all the young kids grow up
watching the slam dunk uh you know this
in the slam the popular the slam dunk
contest
along with the three-point shot uh you
know guys big guys now guys coming over
from europe
are valued because they can shoot the
three-point shot as well and and that's
all well and good i think uh you know
the inside game will come back uh when
someone wins a championship and then
they'll all start emulating it again
exactly uh you know for the life of me i
don't understand why any seven footer
uh doesn't
have a hook shot and relate the sky hook
i i i don't have an answer for that in
this last clip neil degrasse tyson
wanted to know how many three-point
shots kareem abdul-jabbar had taken in
his career oh sit down for this one
let's find out how many i shot 13 and i
made one
so your whole career or you got 10 years
if i did the math right 10 years of your
career was in the presence of the
three-point line right i think that's
right 10 12 something like that okay
so
you had 13 attempts right
and you made one i made one
so of your
38 billion points
38 000 points three of those were a
three-point shot
one three-point shot
and the rest were all free throws and
two-point shot so
uh they don't need the big man outside
the three-point line so what what the
hell were you doing
uh i was giving my team reliable
shots
close to the basket which forced the
defense to collapse a little bit and
gave them more room on the perimeter but
when you go to the perimeter and take a
three-point shot
what were you thinking
i'm probably going to be taken out for
taking that shot
was it come on guys give me a chance
here please no no and the one shot that
i made that the ball i like bounced out
into the corner and i went and got it
and nobody came to guard me okay so i i
stepped back and said okay i'll shoot
this one and
i made it they should have like bronzed
that ball and gave it to you
so jamal
if
he'd shot missed would he have been
given a hard time
oh yeah absolutely
being kareem abdul-jabbar was no
protection right oh no absolutely not
not in that situation not in that
situation
yeah that's so funny uh and and
and i'm sure if you took a three-pointer
people would were expecting you to make
it if kareem takes one they're like okay
well we'll see if he misses he's like
well you know he's not supposed to make
a three but if you miss it they're like
hey what's up what's up
if i could give jamal wilkes a magic
ticket get you entry to any
place to go and watch a basketball game
who would jamal wilkes go and watch
today i would watch the golden state
warriors uh being a former warrior
i cut my teeth with them and they're
playing such a
great great basketball right now yeah
and they're playing it the right way you
know they're getting and by that i mean
you know they're getting everyone
involved and and and they're all
sacrificing for the good of the team yes
yeah i would go watch them and do you
see any simulation any similarities
between uh golden state and and and
showtime because when you said they're
all sacrifices for the good of the team
they have a lot of superstars on that
team
uh and then with the addition of durant
they got one more superstar like so
you know what's it like just give us a
sense
what's the mindset
of
when you're a superstar that guy's a
superstar that guy's a superstar
what has to be the team psychology in
order for you to win because i'm a
sixers fan i remember we had a team full
of superstars when i was a kid and it
was a
yeah
disaster
right all right right just because you
have a team of superstars and i won't
hold that against you chuck for being a
success
well said jamal well said sir yeah well
you know julius is a dear friend but but
first of all it's very humbling
uh you know you walk out and you have
six seven eight superstars
uh well first of all you bring your
a-game to practice and the games every
day because someone's waiting to take
your spot there you go there you go it's
very humbling it's very humbling and and
uh
and then you know the competitive factor
comes out
uh and then and the challenge factor
comes out and you know you want to do
your best to be your best but you know
you got to do your best to get minutes
on the floor too so
uh it just brings about a collective
uh
humility
and then you let all the horses go nice
all right jamal thank you so much for
your time so it's been an absolute
pleasure
talking to you about uh your time
at the lakers and of course kareem
abdul-jabbar so thank you once again we
are going to take a commercial break but
it won't stop there with the lakers
loving we have another one of kareem's
former teammates this time
michael cool
cooper will be with us on play with
science do not go away yeah there you
heard it
back in a minute
welcome back i'm gary o'reilly and i'm
chuck knight and this is playing with
science and today we're in the middle of
our game changer series this particular
show about kareem abdul-jabbar and his
legendary sky hook shot and joining us
by video is michael cooper the legendary
michael cooper the secretary of defense
yeah the man who is now head coach of
the atlanta dream of the wnba
michael what a pleasure to have you on
board welcome to the show
thank you so much and gary i'm going to
tell you preach on yeah
sit sit still there's a lot more going
to come yeah
we've got nothing but praise for you my
friend because uh of course uh you know
kareem being who he was and the show is
about uh you know basically the skyhook
and the science behind it and of course
kareem himself and and you played with
him uh uh and being on the court with
him a soldier at arms with him but you
yourself have quite a few
highlights uh on on the internet that
still live
about michael cooper and i the one thing
i remember about you specifically is
that when you came on the court the fans
would all go
and and then the announcers would say
and the fans showing their appreciation
for michael cooper uh not booing by the
way they're saying coupe you know what i
watching it in in the 80s in the uk
the socks
the what the socks the socks the high
the the crew socks the high top socks
always remember those such a standout
thing but we got a clip right yeah we
got a clip take a ticket just for those
of you who may have forgotten here's a
little taste of the magic not johnson
the magic of michael cooper
not going to guard the inbound passer
now here they send a man out on him now
they change the man and put stockton on
it stockton a short man so coop can get
it in over him
the lakers are out of timeouts no time
outside the ball behind him dribble
drive down
[Applause]
but
there's still seven seconds
and the lakers have no time outs left
but listen to this crowd on cooper's
heroics
and there you have it just uh just a
little taste
of uh what what mr michael cooper used
to do all the time
yeah all the time how's that feel when
you when you look at that you know what
chuck and gary that was my only shot i
hit in that series and it was a big shot
and you know what that goes to show you
that uh the lakers showtime era wasn't
built on one player it was real some
players and for magic to have the
confidence and you know the team knew i
was having a shooting slump but for
magic to have the confidence in me to
kick the basketball out there uh is what
showtime was all about and sean and i
was finally glad to hit a shot and if
that was the one that was gonna win that
series for us i'm glad it was that shot
when you got drafted by the lakers what
was it like the first day you walk out
on court with them the first uh
astounding thing is when i got drafted
by the lakers i came into training camp
and training camp used to be at loyola
marymount university yeah
and i walked into the gym and who would
i see out there shooting sky hooks was
kareem and i just my mouth was open and
i said you know this is the guy i
watched because growing up in los
angeles you saw him at ucla for four
years and right he's got a chance to see
him with the bucks and win a
championship there so finally here he is
with the lakers and i just remember i
couldn't stop staring at him and then
slowly people started coming in and then
there was jabal wilkes uh wanting
winning the championship with the golden
state warriors uh and then finally the
person that i admired a lot because i've
watched them the last two years was norm
nixon yeah yeah i was like
this little guy is that that that good
that big and you know it was uh an
eye-opening experience and i think any
rookie going into a camp no matter what
team you go to they have those stars on
the team and it is it's shocking uh but
you know what you got to get over that
and jerry west was a coach at the time
he said cool you almost kind of like
slapped me back to reality and said come
on man you got to play so it was fun
watching them you know what i think is
funny is that used called norm nixon a
little guy i did a tv show with norm a
little while ago
and standing next to him uh he looked
like he was taking his toddler out to
get some ice cream but
you must be very small damn
norma's a little guy and again sick so
it was it was it was a funny thing to
see
you
okay so you'd have turned up day one
right early because you want to impress
the organization correct yeah kareem was
already firing skyhooks
out there early
and that goes back to his uh
uh his conditioning uh from you know
back with john wooden when he was at
ucla they get out there the bigs would
get out and shoot their hooks and get
their work in then the guards would come
out and then finally the whole team
would come out for practice so he just
followed suit and that's what he knew so
he came out there he was the first one i
saw when i walked into the gym he was
the first person i saw wow shooting
scott hooks but you guys you know what i
want to touch on something gary you had
mentioned a little earlier you talked
about our socks yes uh my socks i held
my socks up high
uh for you know when i was in high
school the reason why i wore long socks
i wore my strings out and i wore two
sweat bands because in a high school
game of the week in 1974 my grandmother
was going to see us play and she had
glaucoma and she had to sit real close
to the tv and they should say hey you
have to do something to differentiate
yourself so i know you from the other
players
so that's what happened with the long
sock little did i know they were gonna
play big benefits because in the 80s you
know we were in that daisy duke era
where the shorts were really yeah
so my socks kind of like even my body
out a little bit
i will thank you for giving me that back
story that's really yeah that's very
very cool okay
as i called you
just before we came on the secretary of
defense that's right how did you
cope with kareem
in practice with those skyhooks or did
you say why am i bothering did you as a
defensive player of the year did you
ever have to when you guys are
practicing uh to defend kareem and did
that help your defensive game
chuck no
i'm glad i've never had to defend him
down there on a double team but no that
was michael thompson okay jim jones
those guys they caught those sky hooks
but it was a thing to see but in
practice again playing on the uh the
purple team because the gold team was
the starters right it was fun and it was
always uh a way of how we're going to
stop this how can we stop the shot and
it was an unstoppable shot right green
just kind of went through the motions
because he knew nobody could stop his
shot in the game of basketball at that
time and especially nobody on our team
so he would just kind of go through the
motions and shoot jumpers shoot
left-hand hooks until it was winning
time because pat riley said okay uh next
point wins the game losers got to run 10
well we knew we were going to end up
running because
[Laughter]
that's funny
i mean there's clips where kareem is
speaking to neil degrasse tyson
about his understanding of the science
that went into his skyhook did you ever
get a feeling with him in the locker
room that this guy had everything calmly
in the right place at the right time was
he as organized at that back then in the
80s yes he was always organized cream
was a quiet individual
he came into the locker room and you
know how some teams will have the locker
room banner and there'll be somebody
funny telling jokes and people do
different things kareem always sat and
he sat next to jamal wilkes
uh
both on being from ucla and creed was
always reading a book
uh some type of book uh using an
autobiography
of african-americans uh some type some
kind of book he was always reading
really but every now and then and people
don't notice about him he
probably was one of my funniest
teammates uh he liked to play practical
jokes every now and then didn't like him
played on him but he played
yeah ain't nothing
everything was always together with him
uh and once we got closer to the game he
would put the book down and he would
just kind of like stare and one day i
asked him i said cat what do you think
about he says coop i'm visualizing the
game in my head what i have to do and it
was always like the first five to seven
minutes so that was his way of getting
focused and getting into the game but
you could tell from then that everything
he did he had planned out in his mind
whether it went right or wrong but at
least it was planned out and he always
came out and perfected his plan michael
before we let you go and we thank you
for your time
i have a simple question
just how good was kareem abdul-jabbar
people ask me that all the time and
there are a lot of great players that
have played in the nba and you've got to
go back to will will chamberlain
bill russell and people ask me coop if
you were starting an nba team and you
had all the players that's ever played
this game yep you picked kareem would
always be my pick and the reason for
that is he had an unstoppable shot
at his prime y'all remember kareem led
this league in rebounding he led the
league in blocked shots one year and the
most important thing is you had a big
guy like kareem that could pop out on
the perimeter but you couldn't follow
him green shot like in the mid 80s uh
for free throw shooting and you know the
way things are going now they have the
hacker shack which started and now they
put these centers on the line and you
know basketball is not fun when it's
played that way but right i'm gonna go
with kareem but there are many many
great ones and uh i might
be dumb but i'm gonna start with the big
guy kareem abdul-jabbar wow would you
pick yourself in your own franchise i
think so good man that that's the answer
i was looking for that's the way it's
supposed to go hey michael thanks so
much for joining us man we hope you'll
come back and uh and say hello and uh
thanks so much for taking the time and
spending with us right now richard chuck
and gary thank you so much for having me
it's a pleasure sir an absolute pleasure
thank you so well that's our show man
that is it uh i hope you've enjoyed it
it's the first of our game changer
series and i think we couldn't have
picked a better start than kareem
abdul-jabbar so stick around we'll have
plenty more i'm sure yeah and special
thanks of course to jamal wilkes and
michael cooper for being a guest on the
show and thank you to kareem
abdul-jabbar
for being such a standout basketball
player and of course the great man
himself neil degrasse tyson for spending
that much time and getting such great
thoughts out of him i'm gary o'reilly
and i'm chuck nice and this has been
playing with science hope you enjoyed it
and we look forward to your company very
very soon
[Music]